i have a question that i really want to
ask i'm scared to ask it but
um are eastern diamondback rattlesnakes
more
deadly than western diamondback
rattlesnakes
i some people told me yes
some people told me that western's more
likely to bite you i've heard back and
forth all i know is they're very closely
related they both got that hemotoxin
some neurotoxin poison in them
and either one
will kill you some somebody told me that
eastern may be a little more toxic
but
both of them will kill you i mean okay
okay so really it's a worse
you know what she's really bad that
little rattlesnake in california
southern pacific
that we remember we played around with
that thing bites you you'll be bleeding
out of your eyes and out of your ears
and out of your nose it dissolves your
brain that thing is probably one of
those deadly snakes in the world the the
one you find around l.a that rattle sink
out there but
they're everywhere in [ __ ] l.a
they're [ __ ] everywhere and the more
they want to get bit by that thing
you will go into convulsions
that thing is horrific horrific snake to
get bit by blue was it was it the snake
that you had on your tick tock maybe i
mean i don't [ __ ] know but but i
didn't know there's rattlesnakes all
over the place and the more that
california gets like super dry
like which is it like they they come
more into where the people are to find
water
so like do you see mac you see
rattlesnakes more and more often and
like i i honestly personally don't even
[ __ ]
give a [ __ ] like i only care about wendy
my dog wendy so
my question is if you see anyone in your
yard just smash them
i'm not gonna do that either but um but
what uh what can i do
for my dog wendy
they could kill your dog very fast they
have rattlesnake courses yeah they do
training we're like if they hear the
shake they're like yeah get rid of that
rattlesink if you catch it throw it away
get rid of them off your property
anywhere near your dog nut i mean
your dog is a thousand times more
important than those reptiles so the
heck of those rattlesnakes you know
when it comes to i got i got my trident
there you go three at once yeah nature's
takes second place when it comes to
family
uh your pet and everything no way no way
i'm not don't take any chances with
those things
you know therefore way out in the
wilderness you want to take your chances
with them play with them that's fine but
no no no that's
in florida right now are thick they're a
lot more remember i had to wait all day
long to get them to come in they'll they
come in a lot quicker now
yeah there's a lot more shark now than
ever
what do you think that they think that's
because
they there's no more heavy duty
commercial fishing for sharks like they
used to be so they you know of course
they were pounded they were overfished
now they're under fish so the population
has grown you know it's called stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and if you
go on amazon and type in stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on amazon and buy stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude